j'ai été convoqué par la direction
d'antenne 2 et la direction ne sais pas
pourquoi d'ailleurs jeudi la direction
pourquoi ce mot est féminin plus qu'avec
des hommes
enfin bon la direction m'a dit pour la
fin d'année de la femme nous invité
françois girault et vous nous faites une
émission spéciale voulu plutôt détendu
plutôt amusante plutôt espiègle avec des
chansons des gags des saynètes etc
alors j'ai répondu à la direction oui
madame bien madame et cette émission en
direct de la rue cognacq-jay la voici
[Musique]
et
e
même le ministre bonsoir mon sens j ciel
et qui dit ouf
ce sont les hommes où sont les femmes je
vois que vous n'êtes pas du tout au
courant non pas du tout vous ne savez
pas la bonne nouvelle vous le dire je
voulais dire les nations unies qui ont
inventé l'année de la femme
eh bien elle vient de décréter la
décennie de la femme disant eh bien pour
une émission qui devait commencer dans
l'amusement tous les hommes parlent les
30 décembre 1985 on ne va pas décréter
le siècle de la femme à meussia c'est
pas mal non plus mais il ya une chose
qui m'étonne beaucoup c'est que les
misogynes au début d'année la femme ne
trouvait pratiquement pas de mystères
est comme des lapins
et puis à la fin d'année de la femme
alors pas du tout alors crânement cyr
mois on en rencontre beaucoup je pensais
avoir des difficultés pour retrouver des
misogynes et pas du tout non nous
correspondait jamais des difficultés
pour un exemple de rentrer maintenant
enfin honte donc les gérantes ah mais
vous même le milanais savaient pas un
peu ras-le-bol aussi nous d'aller de la
femme tout de même parce que quand même
ça fait beaucoup de travail en plus là
pour travailler
oui mais enfin quand même non non non
pas du tout je trouve pas que ça a donné
matière à des plaisanteries parler de la
femme
bien sûr est que la publicité c'est
l'année de la femme alors acheter des
meubles chez intel évidemment c'est un
peu gênant mais pour ce que c'est pas
très grave
superficiel alors la surface des choses
je vous propose est elle un coup d'oeil
sur le décor nous avons mis là les
hommes français de l'année de la femme
le vous reconnaîtrez par exemple vous
avez le juge de charette à côté un
gangster sur les gangsters une
profession en pleine expansion le ci
s'appelle willoquet guide rue guy drut
un peu record du monde du 110 m haies
michel rocard on dit que dans
l'opposition c'est l'homme qui monte
bernard thévenet qui est guidé le tour
de france auto dessus de lui nicolas
peyrac que révélation de la chanson vous
avez géré le bigeard qu'elle va lui
miner cette année et puis il ya des
petits ennuis avec ce vous voyez vous
auriez pu mettre la place d'une
charrette vous arrive à mettre la jeune
femme qui juge la rame du gangster et
puis edith cresson le président michel
rocard n'a pas gagné à chaque année non
plus et la place de guide rue les deux
jeunes femmes ce soir on l'a appris
qu'ils ont gagné leurs amis d'endurance
contre les hommes
enfin sur les amis et pmi la gères tu as
gagné le prix goncourt
ah oui c'est bizarre aux [ __ ] non mais
j'ai pu remarquer une chose tout à fait
singulière c'est que cette année la
femme
aucun prix nobel n'a été décernée ou une
femme ou quelqu'un d'autre qu'un grand
prix éviter la france et les téléphones
et bien je trouve ça excellent trouvé ça
très bien je trouve ça très bien parce
que les bras des pas mieux ça venait pas
du tout et la littérature j'ai très très
très longtemps que les femmes ont fait
la preuve qu'elles peuvent s'illustrer
dans la littérature
il pensait que le jury femina fait
exprès de ne pas décerner son prix le
papillon et je crois que je crois qu'on
ne s'intéresse plus aujourd'hui au point
de savoir si c'est une femme qui a écrit
les moineaux savez qu'il ya des femmes
qui se moque de l'année de la femme
bien sûr ces normes écoutez ça c'est une
telle attitude est persécuté vous savez
bien
quant à parler d'où ça va nous faire du
tort que les c'est bien cette antienne
on l'entend très souvent sud est
personnifiée il existe une chanson qui
se moque allègrement de la femme elle
s'intitule
engagée alors une telle était l'oeuvre
d'un homme
je me serais pas permis de l'inviter à
cela mais je trouve cette chanson a pour
auteur une femme lit d'anne sylvestre
mais c'était le match vous allez
l'entendre elle entend alors voilà
accompagné par henry drault voici la
vache engagé par anne sylvestre -
germaine ctu ça a plus de raison que le
cash l'an prochain parait-il qu'on va
penser au problème
[Musique]
et mieux ne se sont réunis dans un
sursaut d'indépendance
ils ont fait part de leurs soucis ont
exposé leurs doléances
vachon une arme aussi
c'est le métier
alors que donner la main
elle n'en dira tu un supplice et la
machine à traire leurs mamelles des 6 6
[Musique]
outre que c'est humiliant
parce que t'es trop mécanique est aussi
très traumatisant du point de vue de
l'esthétique
les vaches sont une âme aussi
et le laitier
une autre revendication rassemblé 2
juste nature
elle porte sur la façon de traiter leur
projet dit
elles ont en effet compris par intuition
tout babines pour leur fait peur des
petits pour une sinistre cuisine
eva choses ont une âme si
c'est le métier qui me l'a dit
le problème le plus brûlant a trait à
leur vie sexuelle jamais de taureaux
dans leurs champs et papé ne d'être en
effet leur fécondation se fait par un
intermédiaire qui n'inspire pas leur
passion j'ai nommé le futur hinault
et ben achour d'une arme
c'est le métier comme la vie
souhaitant que les autorités dans un
esprit très bon finisseur concède sans
plus tarder ce qui rendra leur vie
moindre
un disent que s'il le fallait et ce
titre r pâturages et pleurer la grève
demain et le boycott du vélo
âge
les vaches ont une âme
et
elles m'ont bien persuadés que leur
plainte ils sont naturelles mais
j'apprends pour leur a donné toute une
année rien on va réunir un congrès sur
la condition des bâches
le président sera là boucher
les vaches n'ont plus de soucis
pour laitiers ou jetés
m
[Musique]
je vois vous n'applaudissez pas la
ministre annonçait entendez des
meilleures chansons d'anne sylvestre
vous n'avez pas celle ci ça trouve pas
très sûr que nous et ryan sylvestre
beaucoup utilisation après il fallait
tenir comme ça parce que c'est le
premier incident m'asseoir et sa série
casse le nez cassé
oui alors cette chanson pourquoi une
chanson contre l'année de la femme alors
pourquoi vous n'êtes pas misogyne
comment justement non je dois dire que
s'il faut que j'explique pourquoi j'ai
fait cette chanson j'ai pas aimé du tout
l'année de la fin parce que s'il faut
vraiment qu'on accorde une année à
toutes les catégories l animal qui en
ont besoin qui sont en détresse
alors je pense que les vaches on a
beaucoup plus besoin avec nous dans
l'ordre d'urgence géré penser que les
femmes sont une catégorie animal de
cette façon oui oui quand on donne une
et oui j'ai saigné
non mais alors pourquoi je suis mais
parce que écouter quand même les vaches
la trayeuse électrique c'est tout le
temps pour elle nous 70 ans seulement
mais pas toutes
pineau enfants il on a tous à la
casserole puis au moins nous explique je
veux dire c'est pas il faut pas tous et
puis et puis on est moins quatre
attaques là enfin on est mieux traité
que vous êtes une féministe contre
l'année de la femme
ah oui mais en plus je n'ai pas de
raisons pour ça je suis du charolais
elle voit la patte à la non mais je suis
pas j'ai trouvé ça agaçant parce que
d'abord sas a augmenté tout les toutes
les moqueries ça augmentait pas mal de
chose quand tu dis c'est tellement
facile puis qu'est-ce qu'il va mener mon
dieu enfin je trouve ça pourquoi la
coopération mais comment l'année de la
population l'année dernière c'est aussi
quelqu'un de rien ni mal un peu plus la
silhouette ce moment là dessus non c'est
parce que non parce que je veux pas
faire les chansons sur tout ce qui se
passe là ça me concerne est il un peu
plus alors je vous avais promis des
misogynes et bien je suis pas allée très
loin pour en trouver à j'ai trouvé sur
antenne 2 1 samedi vers 18 heures je
regardais péplum le magazine du théâtre
de josé artur et voici ce que j'ai vu
entendu je vous allez le voir maintenant
à propos du spectacle ben-hur donné au
sir jean richert vous avez voir le tamis
s'agit d'user tir je le connais très
bien
maintenant on voir et l'émission de
françoise giroud les femmes battues la
défense avec lille avec les lions il ya
une femme attachée dans la cage aux
lions
et puis qui est livré en pâture aux
fauves enfin l'histoire des chrétiens
encaissant alors josé artur ça c'est un
fieffé misogyne ça veut dire que vous
j'ai le courage de devenir d'abord parce
que c'est pas vous roule à prendre mais
en plus je suis un misogyne c'est vrai
mais j'ai pas attendu l'année de la
femme pour l'aide
je le suis plus depuis qu'il y a c'est
vrai un ministère de la femme
oui si je mens gentiment très longuement
très courtoisement alors ça se manifeste
comme h
oui mais je vais tenter de vous envoyer
un compliment et en même temps d'achever
alors encore les vaches non mais c'est à
dire que pour moi pour moi vous n'êtes
pas vous n'êtes pas une femme comme les
autres
non mais c'est vrai j'ai je pense que
les les femmes si vous voulez n'ont pas
attendu un ministère est l'année de la
femme celle qui pouvait et devait sortir
de l'anonymat de louise labé
je ne sais pas edmonde charles roux bon
je dis ça parce que les chargés de
surveiller les programmes donc ça peut
être bon pour moi mais je vais nommer
madame baudrier jamais là parce que ça
peut toujours être utile mais on ne sait
jamais mais les femmes intelligentes
sont des femmes intelligentes
je trouve que le c'est du racisme le
féminisme c'est la même chose ou la
misogynie
c'est dire que un noir on n'ose plus
dire qu'un noir qu'on est con mais et
quand il est coach dit qu'il est quand
une femme qui est bête on va dire le
féminin qui remarquait pas beau on peut
dire nommé qu une femme le féminin je
trouve ça pas très joli alors d'abord ça
nous choque par exemple qu'il soit forcé
de dire madame la ministre
le minime justement que terran c'est de
dire qu'on est mort je me trompe c'est
vrai mais c'est pour dire on devrait
dire madame la ministre est alors moi si
je comprends bien je suis votre bonne
entre guillemets femmes comme vous avez
un bon [ __ ] un bon juif
non mais vous n'êtes pas que vous n'êtes
pas vous n'êtes pas la seule moi je te
le premier vrai que marie curie et ne
puissent pas voter son jardinet j'étais
première ça je te laisse ussama outré et
toujours mais pour moi c'est la seule
école en tournée en tournée par yann
d'un théâtre les femmes ne seront l'égal
de l'homme quand elles portant leurs
valises mais pour moi c'est pas ça du
tout si c'est pas du tout mais si je
suis là déjà
et moi je trouve qu'il n'y a aucun
inconvénient à à rendre service ménager
quelconque un homme moi je suis in the
past elie baup se situent plutôt je suis
d'ailleurs je crois que le problème est
toujours un peu mal posée parce que je
problème alors sérieusement politique
social économique
alors quand on aura réglé quand on aura
éduquer la femme et du quai l'homme dans
le sens de la différence intéressante et
complémentaires moi je serais tout à
fait d'accord vous voyez n'est pas
misogyne mais pour le mas si je suis
misogyne de la façon dont on le présente
maintenant parce que moi je ne m'en
dimanche par le dimanche j'ai pas dans
duke est une fête des mères pour aimer
ma main et je refuse que d'ailleurs vous
verrez que le ministère va changer avant
de s'appeler ministère de la guerre par
exemple dans ce ministère des armées et
vous verrez qu'un jour il veille à 20 la
même mutation
parce que ça va gêner mais je sers
furent si vous étiez marier quand
sociaux commencent manifesterait votre
misogynie à son égard et ben moi vous
savez sérieusement je serai un peu
furieux parce qu'elle a une place
supérieure à la mienne et la page aurait
pas osé vous voyez nous inspirions ce
serait en train de lui repasser ses
chemises non parce que vous pourriez
simplement continuer à faire ce que vous
faisiez c'est à dire quand vous écriviez
moi j'ai lu de ddd livre de vous avant
si je mangeais le tout paris par exemple
les a mangés murs lire un bon de voir
les deux volumes et à 96 portrait ya 26
portraits de femmes quand vous écrivez
ça et vous prenez beaucoup d'étrangers
en plus parce qu'il n'y avait pas
tellement je vous ai entendu les femmes
québec
mais oui mais comme je vous ai entendu
tout à leur faire des critiques sur les
photos je disais que vous avez fait
quelque chose de très grave offense
audio saviez pas les noms des femmes
mais s'est passé beaucoup de nous mais
vous saviez pas les noms des femmes qui
devait remplacer mais la femme de ville
ok vous disiez agen bc on vous avait dit
non la championne qui vous avez les noms
de ceux qui pouvaient remplacer
maintenant je ne sais pas le nom des
deux j'ai remarqué histoire de laisser
tomber
je n'ai pas regardé un jour
moi si vous seriez marié as misogyne
est-ce que qu'elle conseille pas
pratique je n'ai pas oublié de donner au
paradis mais je crois qu'elle aime ça
n'est pas parce que quand même au moment
où marine mention choisit alors ça se
voit tout de suite
moi je suis tout à fait à léran à tous
mais pour laisser les gens bien libre de
mener leur vie comme ils ont dit que les
misogynes sur les meilleurs amants est
ce que c'est vrai
n'ayant jamais fréquenté bon alors voici
donc on les chiens j'ai donc présenté un
chef et miso de la radio et la
télévision je vous en présenter trois
autres oui c'est ça interviewé par anne
sinclair et sur des images de dominique
pages vous allez dans voir tous ces
trois fiefs et misogynes de la radio la
télévision le président marcel jullian
pierre bellemare et jacques martin mais
où suisse tombe est entre les mains une
photo édifiante de vos collaborateurs
vous êtes entourés de 18 ans il ya une
seule femme alors c'est une proportion
qui vont par et g non parce que tu n'es
pas prévu du tout une pomme je me mets
encore qui fait on peut on a beau fermer
les portes on a beau le fait de
travailler sérieusement il ya toujours
un accident et une boutade ou cgg
profond que ça non je vois plus prompt
que j'ai découvert là une femme elle
vous reproche de travailler avec un
harem autour de vous c'est vrai dés que
vous parlez à un homme dans votre visite
bernard pivot de dire que je te
misérable mais heureusement c'est
flagrant c'est flagrant sur la photo on
voit marcel jullian patrons de chaînes
18,1 autant aimé je vous propose une
chose on voit une photo de la pop tout
seul et vous verrez comme ça on lui rend
lui redonner sa dignité
est ce qu'elles avaient de la femme vous
a appris à regarder les femmes
différemment regarde depuis l'enfance
les femmes avec une terreur émerveillé
on sait très bien qu'on ait les oiseaux
piéger ce merveilleux met donc en ville
si on regarde toujours mon comprends
toujours pas elle va vous les regardez
vous les écoutez vous de support méchant
mais je suis quand même plus agréable à
écouter et à regarder guerre et coupé
est l'année de la femme pour vous ça
changeait quelque chose ou pas vous
l'avez ressenti comment occupez vous me
disiez tout à l'heure qu'une année de
quelque chose c'est toujours dangereux
c'est pour ça que j'ai fait attention
parce qu'il sort toujours dangereux pour
les gens qu'on commémore pour les quand
on vous dit cela remet le nez napoléon
pouvait plus supporter une abeille
quand on vous dit que c'est l'année de
la commémoration de la guerre de 14-18
vous pouvais plus supporter quelques
grillades et médaille parce qu'on en
voit trop c'est ces terrifiantes
commémorer quand on commémore on rend
pas service
alors moi j'ai toujours pensé qu'il
fallait avoir une pudeur à l'égard de
l'allée de la femme d'alors flux d'air
est un mot essentiellement féminin et
qu'il fallait le traiter comme si on
avait oublié ce qu'était la façon de
commémorer en silence comme les grandes
grues moral et vous avez payé votre
tribu cette année vous allez vous vengez
l'année prochaine non réclame non
miranville qu' il y en avait une on va
pas la tuer parce qu'elle va quand même
faut quand même pas on n'a pas cette
férocité avec une dans la photographie
ou si on est encore là l'année prochaine
on fera une autre photo avec une femme
peut-être une autre parce qu'on se sera
plus classée
de vaux habituel camarades de régiment
comme les roulants comme jean-marc
epinoux par exemple que j'aime et femmes
dans votre équipe
pourquoi je suis l'homme non non parce
qu'il est très difficile de trouver
d'une femme animatrice jérémy mais c'est
difficile
non on a remarqué que lorsque l'on voit
les entrées de cinéma en général c'est
quand même la vedette masculine qui fait
les intérêts davantage que révèlent ces
mines sauf cas d'exception comme madame
bardot une certaine époque mais
finalement ma carrière masculine est
plus longue
je n'avais pas l'impression qu'un
sourire a ajouté aux moustaches de
jean-paul rouland serait plus agréable
si sûrement à 6,6 sûrement sûrement
seulement c'est très difficile encore
une fois trouvé il ya quelques
animatrice ça ne me semble pas
totalement métiers féminins facilité on
voit la difficulté à travailler avec
vous au nom les gens qui travaillent
avec moi je suis très content de
travailler avec moi vous n'êtes pas
nomme mise à j or j'en sais rien il est
plus facile d'être ami avec un homme qui
avec une femme c'est certain parce qu'on
ne sait pas très bien où il faut que ça
arrête l'amitié n'est ce pas alors qu'on
ne sait avec un homme à moins d'être un
peu particulier vous avez un ton un peu
boy scout quand vous parlez aux hommes
vous parler aux femmes sur un ton un peu
différent est ce que c'est de la
différence est ce que c'est au contraire
un point de plus qu'à 100 vous n'êtes
pas conscient de ça non non je pense des
vieux fond de dire un prix française
la galanterie pas un peu de méfiance non
dieu en plus de ça de la timidité parce
que les hommes publics en génération de
sont souvent timides
est-ce que vous avez l'impression que
vos collaboratrice sont plutôt plus
contestataire que vos candidates sont
plutôt plus nombreuses ou que votre
femme est plutôt moins d s'il jure que
je n'ai strictement rien changé de
refrain je ne suis pas très bien à quoi
ça servirait de la femme bien il avait
passé
non pas du tout absolument pas on a vu
un dimanche une femme dans l'équipe du
petit rapporteur et elle a disparu
elle vous a pas s'ils partaient
absolument pas c'est une journaliste qui
voyage énormément et qui est appelée
très souvent pour son métier à l'autre
bout de la terre et comme je la
comprends lorsqu'il m'a dit je vais
faire un petit sujet arrive ou un autre
vainqueur tant que vous n'avez pas
remplacé parce qu'il est très difficile
et c'est pas du tout je pense que notre
métier vraiment un métier d'homme
vous savez pas travailler avec une femme
écoutez j'ai toujours peur en prenant au
point de tels risques pour nos sujets
que je touche en tant qu il arrive un
accident où vous vous répondez à deux
annonces matrimoniales lune qui serait
rédigée comme sa veuve catholique
fortunés recherche du mariage et caetera
et l'autre qui ferait jeune mère
célibataire mannequins très affectueux
je prendrai les veuves catholique parce
que vu leur formation sur des grandes
vicieuse assez profondément misogyne
absolument pas je l'étais élevé chez les
jésuites alors chez les soeurs je sais
ce que ça me préparer à une voluptueuse
cette année de la femme vous l'avez
traversée dans la plus totale
indifférence
non pas du tout enfin je crois que elle
a été accueillie dans la plus grande
indifférence bien et vous c'est une idée
des femmes
le téléphone c'est une idée des femmes
de s'imaginer qu'on vous traite comme
des choses c'est exactement comme si je
disais vous nous prenez souvent pour des
matchs à apporter de l'argent en fin de
mois vous nous sommes bons qu'à cela
c'est ça je me demande dans quel donc l
esprit on a pu on a pu envisager afin d'
abus inventé cette espèce de deux faux
problème c'est un faux problème
je le considère qu'il n'y en a pas tant
le ministre que pensez-vous tout ça je
les trouve merveilleux mais je dois dire
que je suis assez d'accord avec marcel
jullian anne sinclair est beaucoup plus
agréable à regarder que ces trois
messieurs en particulier le dernier qui
était pas très joli mais pas rasé et
mêmes que les deux autres et elle est
aussi agréable entendre de mon point de
vue donc c'est la femme que vous
préférez la 2 par les quatre personnages
nous avons vu cette année la femme à
voter pour le côté esthétique il est
question ne se pose pas mille passionnés
cette équipe et pour le reste c'est
d'être très bonne journée
moi j'aime aller défendre vos confrères
ça mais j'ai noté des choses parce que
m'amuser
marcel jullian a dit que
voir une femme que l'entendre je vous ai
vu ticket madame je trouve ça assez
drôle quand je pense au nombre d'hommes
que je n'ai pas le courage n'entendre
n'est ce pas il ya des imbéciles dans
les deux cas et puis la pudeur est ce
que c'est une qualité essentiellement
féminine ce que nathan lawson y voit
aucun inconvénient à considérer que
c'est une qualité féminine en tout cas
ses qualités plaisante chez les femmes
dirais-je et puis l'année de jukebox à
l'ère des rites et tout le monde le fait
et puis ces foules
c'est vrai nous vous savez qu'au japon
il ya eu une année en même temps qui
viennent ce qui s'écoule qui se termine
donné dans le monde entier non c'était
l'année de la carte
c'est vrai et au chili et l année des
cochons non c'est tout à fait autre
chose d'abord c'est pas le cochon je
crois que vous trompez et ensuite c'est
parce qu'en schyle ce que nous appelons
aussi les signes du zodiaque
ils ce sont les animaux c'était l'année
du lapin je suis informé équipe et non
seulement à paris mais je crois aussi
l'année du lapin et nous sommes
maintenant dans une autre année le mini
jeu de passes et agriculture non mais
vous savez d'un ancien métier j'ai gardé
l'habitude du goût de l'information
exacte mais vous pensez que comme le dit
jacques martin que c'est un métier
dangereux pour les femmes ce métier de
soin de faire rire les gens soient de on
se remettra ses alliés dangereux pour
les hommes parce que si elle y était
très bonne en effet le deviendrai
concluante
je remarque quand même un phénomène
qu'aucun de ces messieurs n'a l'air
d'avoir remarqué c'est que cette année
les femmes ont fait une irruption en
force à la radio où elles sont
excellents et même à la télévision
puisque si je ne me trompe sur la
deuxième chaîne une femme ravissante et
très agréable à entendre qu'il s'appelle
el abida présente un journal à 6h30 bien
ça n'était jamais arrivé la dernière
s'il existe des femmes chirurgienne il
en existe très peu alors nous nous en
avons trouvé lui trouver une salle et la
voir bientôt
j'appuie c'est ma p'tite [ __ ] dans dix
secondes beezik menteuse et josée dayan
qui l'a trouvée oui c'est un film qui
par josé dire josé et e
attention c'est pas
vous inquiétez pas tout va très bien
e
ce père
on peut commencer
beto est
[Musique]
on n'entend pas le son ce qui se passe
c'est julie
oui qui était sûr de bien j'ai pas
reconnaît jean louis alors le pas sur
les tests bien entendu le monsieur
criait non pas une femme non pas une
femme c'est forcément amène à demander à
josé artur s'il se laisserait ouvrir le
vendre par une femme
mais si vous deviez passer si vous
deviez passer si je devais y passe
il ya un malentendu
et là je voudrais rétablir ça c'est que
les misogynes c'est très crus chose
qu'il ait dit que quand on regarde les
femmes
quand on aime les femmes dans la vie on
les observe et quand on les observe
vraiment on a tendance à devenir un peu
misogyne donc par définition si on est
misogyne c'est qu'on aime les femmes
puisque on y observe mais je vois que
ces programmes on a tendance à les
observer il ya très peu de deux sont des
chaussées la télé ces homosexuels j'ai
gagné mais des et n'offrent pas dit ça
mais je veux dire que in sont rares mots
misogyne jeu il adore j'étais passé
remarqué tous les amis homosexuels qu'on
peut avoir sont toujours des vieilles
dames des jeunes dames aux to fall t
soit adorable pourquoi parce que il ne
s'en servent pas si j'ose des élites et
les et les femmes se servent des hommes
alors évidemment on voit les
inconvénients que le plus grand musée
jean c'est toujours absolument c'est
vrai ça c'est fondamental et c'est ça
qui est important
alors un autre fief et miso excusé lors
don juan je n'ai pas pu le trouver et
j'ai trouvé un officier femise hausse et
siècle et miso de la marine à voile il
s'appelle marc lynn ce qui est il a
publié récemment un livre depuis la
voile sauvage est un guide de haute mer
et il a été interviewé par gilles
lambert sur des images dominique pages
les hommes arrivent avec leurs femmes
sur la panne les accompagnent et on sent
qu'ils ont envie de monter à bord tout
de suite très vite il leur dit on semble
assez lâche moi le plus il faut que
j'embarque et puis il ya les fameux
éplorée sur le quai on par y vivent une
semaine une vie de liberté totale sans
leurs femmes sans rien et quand on
revient au port le dernier jour de stage
leur femme est à nouveau sur la panne et
de loin il la voit et on voit le masque
qui revient tout sept explosions qui ont
eu une aventure pendant une semaine de
liberté de tranquillité ils ont tout
oublié
pas pire on voit les problèmes matériels
et par leur femme qui est sur le bout de
la plagne en tant que vous dites c'est
régulier pour coup foutent le camp pour
être débarrassés de tout ce qui concerne
à terre et compris des tables ça c'est
très souvent il vient de retrouver une
certaine liberté incertain certains
s'aventurent une certaine confusion dans
les tripes et puis qu'il arrive pas
exprimé à terre parce que les femmes
finalement les les emmitouflés ocon et
tout ce qu'ils ont dans les tripes ce
qu'on a tous vraiment nous les hommes se
sent aventure sans à grand les types qui
ont traversé les océans - dossier en mai
les grands créateurs
finalement il ya tout ça dans chaque
homme et ils viennent un peu ils
affrontent la haute mer sont débarrassés
de cette gang dont fait partie la femme
à terre et ils ont tous une certaine
liberté d'homme entre hommes et souvent
on a des problèmes quand tu es une femme
à bord vous dites qui sèment la panique
et j'étais même une fois une fois un
alain ya une femme cathy militante toute
féminine la nette domination féminine
équité trouille brutalement devant sa
condition physique elle a pas fait le
poids
le lendemain le vent était plus faible
et est allié en dix ans
en raison du charnois un des hommes du
beurre et laissez les alliés et dont
l'équipage j'ai commencé à avoir un
instrument les esprits j'étais obligé de
la virée du bateau carrément à calvi
j'ai foutu dehors je dis voilà tu pars
tu reprends l'avion on est reparti et
skype cet équipage d'hommes et tout
s'est bien passé ça a été une fin de
stage fantastique marquée si vous avez
plusieurs fois deux fois l'atlantique en
solitaire il n'y a pas de femmes
navigatrice solitaire ci est bien sûr il
y en a eu plus que la dernière fois en
atlantique en solitaire il ya eu deux
femmes
qui ont fait cette coupe et qui sont
arrivés et deux sur des petits bateaux
maisons quand même les qualités morales
mais c'est une exception et u2 dans le
monde la majorité les cours du riz des
mâles il émerveillé vrai et je me suis
absolument d'accord c'est très agréable
de sang et les bijoux ressent hommes de
d'abandonner cesser ses soucis de s'en
aller c'est tout à fait normal
je vais savoir aussi que le livre de ce
fief et miso d'un marine à voile son
livre préfacé par michel poniatowski qui
n'est pas du tout aller pas misogyne oui
qu'est-ce que oui mais je voulais dire
une chose c'est que récemment est paru
un livre un recueil de nouvelles d'une
dame qui biologie je crois que ça pète
christiane baroche sûr que nous-mêmes
s'intitule les feux du large et elle
montre que très souvent parce qu'elle
connaît très bien la navigation à voile
que les femmes sont meilleurs marins que
les hommes il faudra que j'en vois ce
que des visuels qui missionne qui sont
de grands marins et des hommes qui sont
vos loisirs tout à l'air des imbéciles
mais ce qui m'a frappé c'est cette
phrase mer des lieux jusqu'à dit ce
monsieur c'est le grand créateur qui lie
à au coeur de tout eh ben je ne sais pas
qui ils fréquentent ce monsieur mais moi
je voudrais bien voir le grand créateur
qui est au coeur de l'état mais vous
pensez que s'il y avait une femme sur la
caravelle de christophe colomb jamais
découvert l'amérique
je ne sais pas c'est une autre histoire
comment ça c'est une femme sur un bateau
ou pas il dit que c'est une vague jean
matteau ça y est c'est il ya chez les
hommes quelque chose qui est
profondément les pousse à aller plus
loin plus haut plus vite etc c'est un
conte et avions le moteur du progrès
c'est très important ce qu'ils gardent
chez les hommes et qui les pousse comme
ça moi je crois qu'il ya une raison très
profond là ça c'est qu'ils ne pourront
pas d'enfant et le premier homme qui
s'est aperçu qu'il ne pouvait pas faire
un enfant que c'était une femme qui crée
cette chose merveilleuse qui est un
enfant ce premier homme s'est dit il
faut que je fasse quelque chose et
c'était promettait il a été dérobée le
feu qu'est ce qu'on peut faire de mieux
qu'un enfant il n'arrive pas alors
depuis ont été jusqu'à faire la
meilleure actrice yeux et astucieux
c'est l'homme qui crée l'enfance abri à
aa tout à fait différent oui mais on
n'est jamais sûr non prenez frôlé la
catastrophe une catastrophe nucléaire
abominable
il reste 500 millions de femmes est un
mec
d'abord il est très fatigué et admettons
que le premier enfant
bon soit des garçons des filles ça
marche quand même le mot si c'est le
contraire et que ce soit un garçon ça
risque de se voir mourir le globe
il suffit d'un garçon pour faire toutes
sortes et non mais s'il ya plus de
femmes
revenons sur terre
revenons sur terre je vous propose je
vous propose même le ministre un autre
fief et miso sauter un autre préfet miso
louis féraud de la haute couture c'est
inattendu allé le voir et qu'il était le
seul au contraire si j'ose dire
vous aurez ce que c'est difficile de
travailler constamment avec des fins je
crois que oui je crois que oui je suis
un peu plus ce qui explique que dans mon
futur pas tellement de gars qui aime les
femmes en dehors de deux mois alors
dites-moi est-ce que vous avez quelque
chose à leur reprocher
j'ai tout à leurs proches j'ai un paquet
de trucs à la reprocher à un
vraisemblable
elles sont elles sont soigneusement
quand il ne faut pas être soigné elles
sont débraillé quand il faudrait être
très habillée elle son inconsistance
quand il faudrait être concise et vice
versa elles sont elles sont tendres
quand il leur faudrait être être être
dure et dure quand il leur faudrait être
maligne sont elles sont
incompréhensibles
je suis l'homme qui veut milieu des
femmes puisque je leur reproche c'est
finalement de ne pas les comprendre
je comprends rien c'est pour ça que ça
ça reproche elle marche à contre-temps
mais pourquoi d'après vous le marché à
contre temps pourquoi le marchand parce
que sans les femmes
parce que oui parce que ce sont des
femmes je crois que c'est pas du tout un
engagement non annonce est un langage à
bon dos mil alors un petit peu de les
mépriser le même nom ah non non pas du
tout il est fasciné visiblement ah bon
ah oui il faudra comprendre et soupe de
pâte à la hauteur alors aux terres non
mais les aime il dit qu'il ne comprend
pas les 3 il est agacé il est fasciné il
peut pas ça il peut pas s'en défaire
quand ils disent et sa publicité mille
ferro adore les fameux trouve que c'est
du lycée qui n'est pas mensongère mais
enfin je suis persuadé soutien je trouve
que c'est un langage de bons donc tu as
tout va bien ici a vraiment ne sommes
pas misogyne je vous la preuve je vous
administre la preuve c'est que il ya
quatre caméras autour de vue eh bien ces
quatre caméras sont tenus par quatre
cadres eu des pressions du cadreur
femmes car le drame
avoir quatre cadres heures je voudrais
bien que ces cadres eux ce grain ce
cadre elle-même est ce qu'on peut abel
et voilà bon on les voit voyez vous
voici 3 et oui c'est la quatrième fois
la loire de cette haine qui montre les
trois au jury alors ça comme une preuve
toute la mer ou la voir les on les voit
l'avouer
donc il ya des cadres eux et puis alors
là la mission réaliser
la réalisatrice et aux aînés je vais
dire c'est agnès de l'arrivée je
voudrais qu agnès de la rive lauaki qui
dirige tout ça et qu'on nous montre à
bas la voici année cela arrive
voyez agnès de la rive
ce réalisatrice son réalisateur femmes
en direct je ne sais comment on dit est
ce que c'est c'est plutôt un métier
d'homme
comment se fait-il que vous soyez pas
revenue je pense pas qu'ils aient
particulièrement des femmes
il ya des médias qu'on apprend enfin une
femme on essaie de le faire bien et même
le ministre si je dis qu agnès de la
rive non seulement est une excellente
professionnelle l'excellente
réalisatrice mais si j qu'en plus elle
est très belle est ce que c'est une
phrase une fois c'est pas une fois ce
biseau j'avais cru jeudi elle était
passée par ici on laisse entendre que
oui une femme est très
professionnellement est excellente
seulement on laisse entendre qu'elle
n'est pas très bien physiquement alors
quand on ajoute qu'elle est belle c'est
la grande surprise c'est une revanche
constance dit oui bien sûr elle sait
écrire
qu'est ce que voulez vous savez tout
droit ventes mais pas belle elle doit y
avoir des envies dans sa vie privée
alors évidemment c'est troublant quand
on voit en plus une femme agnès de la
rive d'olt ton vous appelez réalisatrice
ou réalisateurs femme bien moi j'ai
l'habitude de me faire un peu réalise à
faire ce que je tiens des premiers des
premières femmes à faire ce métier mais
enfin je pense que maintenant on est
assez nombreux et réalisatrice de
non-gestion choisit pas maintenant en
scène alors il piquait un réalisateur
déjanté compliqué mais devoir expliquer
qu'une réalisatrice est une femme
metteur en scène va compliquer encore
alors j'ai nous avons là sur le plateau
aux mauries chapleau quétin d'experts
parce que nos et chaque plan est un
grammairien éminent drame est rien et il
parle très bien le français
et alors maury chapelon qu'est-ce qu'on
va dire monteuse motor-home parce que
dira la féminisation des noms masculins
pour les métiers autrefois au 19e siècle
occupés par les hommes qu'ils sont de
plus en plus occupés par les femmes et
personnellement ça très bien eh bien il
ya un problème non pas du tout je tiens
tout de suite après c'est dans cette
émission je ne suis pas misogyne je suis
anti féministe et une nuits c'est exact
c'est à dire que par amour des femmes je
suis contre celles qui ont tendance
parfois manifeste que vous entendez
parler de grammaire interview jean marie
claire
avant de venir ici et vous en pensez du
bien mais avec des nuances
je suis comédien alors hop et du
psychologique
je suis de l'avis de jean comme de
grandin gheist comme sur dinan bruno
comme albert ii il y avait les rubriques
du monde sait qu'il est absolument
inadmissible de penser que les conquêtes
du féminisme ne sera pas marquée par une
conquête du féminin dans les noms de
métiers il n'y a pas de raison et par
hommage aux femmes je vous appellerai
moi madame la ministre
et c'est absolument normal car on dit
juste que madame la ministre qui est
sous secrétaires d'état ont dit que
selah sue cette année table c'est une
souche secrétaire d'état cd selon la
beta on dit la secrétaire d'état s'était
traduire une femme
fabre autrefois c'était comme ça ça a
été comme ça dès qu'il ya eu des femmes
qui ont été dans ce poste là il ya des
années c'était comme ça et on a fini par
muschi par masculiniser pourquoi parce
qu'il ya les femmes à partir s'occuper
d'elle woods lee
en ce moment tout de même un essai bien
leurs droits car on a mis du temps
puisqu'il faut pas oublier qu'au point
de vue religieux enfin si on y croit on
n'est ce pas il a fallu attendre un
consignes qu'ils aient lieu je crois au
4e siècle pour que tous les cols et
théologien de l'époque les évêques les
cardinaux se réunissent pour savoir
enfin ce que les femmes en cuisine ils
ont fini par dire oui ils ont fini par
dire oui ils ont fini par dire oui mais
ça a tenu
peut-être une petite comme l'émission de
jean paulhan alors moi je pense qu'il
faut carrément fait ici a aucune raison
de ne pas le faire et si les femmes s'y
refuse c'est par un complexe
d'infériorité et elle pense qu'on ne
prendra pas au sérieux
si les métier qu'elle exerce ont une
raison simple en sommes d'accord permet
il ya des noms de métiers pour lesquels
une petite difficulté tous les noms qui
termine par un nommé par exemple aucune
raison ou barney accentué comme député
on peut faire le féminin facilement a
développé le député e
n'est ce pas un ministre une ministre
aucune difficulté n'est ce pas bon pour
le mot docteur il ya une particularité
c'est qu'il s'agit du titre
universitaire du titre universitaire la
médecine on dit un docteur une femme
sera docteur ès lettres mais l'usagé
très vieux c'est maintenant on cherche à
recruter sur l' usage l'usagé est est
très très très bon en fait relativement
cdk eu des femmes qui ont été docteur en
médecine on a fait très régulièrement en
france et le féminin dr
là on peut pas lire médecine parce que
métier confusion avec en français les
mots ont un sexe est bon et en allemand
ils en ont 3 mais alors pour l'avocat
alors l'avocat ben 10 avocats qui est
absolument la cure oui mais ont dit
n'être qu'à partir du moment où m
dans les circonstances assez
particulières voila voila c'est rare
alors mon cher mais ça fait très très
vite imaginez avec linda wati de
m'affirmer presse savamment tellement
cher m il passe du féminin au masculin
nombre de changements dans leur langue
ils sont relativement faciles en anglais
officiellement maintenant on envie de
rire on peut plus dire par exemple
chairman mondial cherchait un peu plus
dire farman compris c'est relativement
facile il ya tout usage des auteurs
d'une très grande maison d'édition il
s'appelle magro vo et ce guide a été
remis à tous les auteurs en étendard dix
ans voilà les tournures de phrases et
les vous que vous ne devaient plus
employer mais en france est encore une
fois qu'on dise maintenant madame la
mine où moi personnellement j'ai un jour
mais comment dérange pas du tout
simplement il est une tradition une
influence et interviews poney initiative
vient vous porter le drapeau
la raison j'espérais d'autant moins
d'inconvénients que comme c'est une
expression qui écorche le nom de madame
le ministre entend très souvent des gens
me dire ce qui évidemment qu'elle est la
seule à ne pas s'appeler comme ça
justement très difficile de la pause et
même la ministre pour ce qui est égalité
des sexes dans la grammaire il y aurait
beaucoup à faire parce que je vous
donner un exemple si je le dis françoise
giroud emmerich appelants sont bons et
beaux doit employer le masque mais vous
êtes ministre et nul ne sait rien alors
pourquoi pas mal d'argent sur lui la
facilité en des ministres passent et
gamma est rien
toujours très bien sûr que l'illégalité
justifierait qu'on change le pluriel
mais ce qui est agaçant c'est qu'il y
est un titre il emporte sur l'autre quel
qu'il soit plus frappant c'est jeudi un
million de femmes et mauritia plans sont
tombés amoureux
je dois employer le matin alors qu'il
est seul pour un million c'est quand
même une nuit ne vous choque pas à ça me
choque profondément balog jegun moyens
madame la ministre il ya quand même mon
avis un confrère
notre confrère éducation nationale et
c'est que peut-être la seule façon de
s'en sortir c'est de proposer ya eu une
année de la femme
bon eh bien il faudrait faire au point
de vue grammatical que une année sur
l'autre n'est ce pas en face la crau
m'inspirer puis nani au film est beau
ballon mais ça n'a pas lu mais on le
saurait pas ça c'est pas plus que
supprimer les aides et vise à faire d un
mélange
j'aurai sur le calendrier a le temps il
aurait été cette année les accords au
masculin puis l'année suivante aux
femmes à la maison quand même non
[Musique]
monsieur le grammairien ya une chance
une attaque jeune âge je prends des
objections mon président ça c'est une
attaque ad hominem
on devrait parler animal dans une dans
une émission de cette tenue est
important parce que justement je voulais
le placer la belgique aeternam le faire
ça n'aurait pas d'un portrait que
l'espace quand on voyage
mais voyez voyez moi je vous appelez
passagers ou usagés gagner du temps pour
choisir je trouve que les femmes entre
autres le jour elles accepteront d'être
chaude et trouver ça et les gorilles a
nié qu'il change a nommé patrick
allemand que non médicalement ce très
beau couple on mettra lui mais vous êtes
quand même période
ma femme est très grave à mon avis c'est
que actuellement nous allons vers une
évolution où les femmes
n'est ce pas se masculinise de plus en
plus n'est ce pas quand elle occupe un
poste veulent qu'on en parle au masculin
mais pas maintenant maintenant elle
s'habille non mais c'est un fait ça
n'ont pratiquement aucune au doctorat je
t'aime papa ça c'est qu'un cinq mois je
fais ça fait l'enquêté n'est ce pas mais
je vous refais je peux juste des gens
qui ont fait des enquêtes sur la
question comme intervient vous dise donc
il ya une tendance à donner des noms
masculins métier féline et les femmes
ont tendance à se faire des silhouettes
masculines maintenant maintenant si vous
voulez pour résumer très vite et femmes
ont dit oui par exemple mais sa mort
n'est pas le temps et pas non mais pas
mal d'à côté se trouve la femme
ravissante en ce moment avec de longs
cheveux qui leur tombent mais moi je
suis ravi sa maison maintenant des
postes des poches et les messieurs
maintenant on les sacs à main mais tout
ça est très bien mais tellement bien à
force de rationnel rationnel on arrive
en 2000 2001
on parlera des femmes au masculin comme
au féminin mais on arrivera à des formes
et les tomates on dira par exemple à
balan d'une femme n'est ce pas ce grand
femme ne veut pas épouser une petite
venir la grammaire
avez vous une explication psychologique
monsieur l'éminent grammairien oui amour
et masculin au singulier efféminé au
pluriel
il ya des riches et les trois incendies
explications explication médicale amour
était purement féminin n'est ce pas
vient ensuite hissé masculiniser mais le
mot amour masculin au singulier et
masculin au pluriel s'applique à l'amour
chaque fois qu'il s'agit pas des
rapports millions mais d'une femme c'est
seulement quand il s'agit des rapports
amoureux qu'on peut employer au pluriel
le féminin et quelquefois les poètes 1.2
singulier aux familles les dernières
questions
oui le mot espèce qui est un mot féminin
à une certaine tendance à glisser une
espèce de wii ont commis une faute
quelque chose quelque chose d'assez
particulier cette faute est déjà dans
goncourt palu temps de jeu de militants
d'edmond parce qu'il manque de moyens
bien que jules n'est pas qu'un jeu
démarre le journal des grands courts et
s2 fieffé miso et là on trouve un espèce
dans le journal des goncourt mais le
phénomène est quand même explicable
c'est à dire que le mot espèce est un
mot séminaire n'est ce pas mais comme on
l'apprend toujours dans des tournures
comme une espèce 2 n'est pas ça veut
dire quelque chose qui certains espaces
a fini par celle fictive et et ce mot
bien qu'étant un substantif féminin
finit par être confondu avec un un
adjectif comme serpent n'est ce pas et
prend le genre du mot qu'il détermine en
somme d'humour suivants jusqu'au bout
alors on dira un espace un espèce
d'imbécile
c'est très curieux
en effet dans le dictionnaire le mot
historienne n'y était pas le motion
était patent littré par exemple litres
et vous dit que historiens bon c'est un
mot masculin et que historienne ne
s'emploie configurer défaillance à
l'usagé mehiaoui
parle que de m'isoler femmes les traits
vous connaissez l'histoire délit très
surpris ni très se trouvait pardonnez
moi et dans un lit avec sa domestique
lorsque sa femme ouvert la porte et a
dit au monsieur
je suis surprise et litres a répondu non
madame vous êtes vitae mais c'est nous
qui sommes sereins madame la ministre
vien paraître lundi cette commission
représente apple vous permettez je vous
en prie vient de paraître un double 33
cm un double disque intitulé 1975
l'année des femmes
oui alors autour des chansons très
connues charmante comme femme que vous
êtes je lis par jean lumière femmes de
france par maurice chevalier
bonsoir je lis madame par charles trenet
vous les femmes par enrico macias et et
puis beaucoup d'autres chansons et il y
à cette chanson est situé très célèbre
mon homme qui est chanté l'a su par
mistinguett
alors madame la ministre je vous demande
de bien entendre on va vous chanter
cette chanson est elle à lui s'est pas
vu toutes les luttes féministes qui se
déroule actuellement vous allez écouter
les paroles cette chanson à la lumière
de ces luttes féministes et vous pourrez
interrompt d'ailleurs les lieux la
chanteuses et chanteurs
alors voici donc mon homme interprété
par marie thérèse haut rhin est
accompagnée au piano par jean bertho là
sur cette terre ma seule joie mon seul
bonheur simon j'ai donné tout ce que
j'ai mon amour est tout mon coeur un
monde et même la nuit
grange rêve serait de lui ni de monde
ce n'est pas qu'ils soient beaux qu'ils
soient riches ni costaud cet idiot et me
fous des coûts il me prend mes sous je
suis à bois mais malgré que voulez vous
stop stop non parce qu'il allait
vraiment des phrases qui doivent vous
alignez falloir imf ou des coups il me
prend des sous je suis à bout mais ça
doit vous plaire ou qui aimait les
femmes battues chansons d'amour d'amour
vache comme dirait exprimer l'amour mais
c'est une chanson d'amour
alors on peut très bien leur tournée je
peux très bien imaginer il monte en
chantant cette invention parlons d'une
femme avec de tout petits changements
chez les écrire je devrais d'accord
alors marie thérèse haut-rhin si vous
voulez continuer quoi qu'il en soit que
vous les jeunes est tellement dans la
peau de jean bien mal
dès qu'ils s'approchent lui je suis à
lui quand ses yeux sur moi de mon
j'apprends tout chaud
[Musique]
e
je l' ai tellement dans la presse pour
moindrement
il me fait faire n'importe quoi
je tuerai ma foi sans qu'ils me
rendraient
comme je suis une femme
je l' ai tellement dans la peau alors
j'attire votre attention madame la
ministre sur wii centimes ce sens qu'ils
me rendraient qui me ferait devenir un
femme
oui je sens qu'elle me ferais devenir
infâme cette sacrée bonne femme
oui j'ai chanté écoutez là on en
demandait un tout petit peu tôt mais
berthe ama pourrait très bien chanté la
version bon alors écoutez une ligne
marie thérèse aura voulait continuer
avec les femmes puis nous passerons à la
nation pour le quitter c'est fou faire
d'autre entre nous voyez vous il ne
valent pas très cher tous les hommes
[Musique]
souffrir par les eaux dans les bals j'ai
couru afin d'oublier gbu rien à faire
j'ai pas pu quand il me dit viens je
suis comme un chien y'a pas moyen
c'est comme un lien qui vont retenir
je laisse clairement dans la peau jean
suit d'abord que c'est dynamo associe
plus
ceux ci vont devenir la première
manche était la pierre
je lai demandant la peau
ensuite à nous connaître sous son vrai
jour
je dis qu'il faut qu'on pardonne
quand une femme se d'eau
[Musique]
oh
ce qu'elle a dans la quelle est gratinée
les belles belles écouter dans un sens
ou dans l'autre
c'est une belle façon comme ça vous leur
tapez pas tout de même la femme à vrai
dire n'est fait que pour souffrir je
suis comme un chien très bien il monte
en dix ans la femme la femme à vrai dire
n'est fait que pour faire souffrir
ben alors vous voulez couleur verte là
vous voulez vous alors un petit peu voit
un petit peu pour voir ce que ça
donnerait allez voir ça va très bien 1
alors cela dit alors l'auteur des
paroles monsieur yves un rallye va
porter ses dires c'est un homme qui crie
vérifier sécurité tout de même non parce
que ce n'était pas il faut dire aux
téléspectateurs
ça n'était pas prévu du tout ça alors
évidemment mais agnès de la rive est une
femme épatante et de jean bertho l'on
peut y aller
en même temps sur cette terre ma seule
joie mon seul bonheur c'est ma môme et
j'ai donné tout ce que j'ai mon amour
est tout mon coeur à maman et même la
nuit
quand je rêve c'est de qui de ma môme
ce n'est pas qu'elle soit blonde qu'elle
soit riche ou même giron mais je
l'aimais comme un fou m foulée cours
elle promet sous
je suis à bout mais malgré tout que
voulez vous
je n'ai tellement dans la peau de jean
simard tôt mais qu'elle me touche c'est
fini je suis soumise
quand ses yeux sur moi se pose
ça me rend tout chaud
[Musique]
je l' ai tellement dans la poule
rejoindre au bout
elle préfère n'importe quoi je tuerai ma
foi je sens qu'elle réviserait femmes
cette sacrée bonne femme
[Musique]
et je l' ai tellement dans la peau
on applaudit la parolière droit madame
unis oui madame la ministre vous avez
gagné le droit d'y aller vous avez écrit
des chansons mais c'est pour ça
évidemment elle vous fait une chanson
coller ça oui sauf que parent de mille
tonnes dès qu on sait enfin il ya des
hommes il ya des sommes qu'ils paient
pour se faire battre
ça n'avait quand vous promener dans
paris il ya 3 4 rue où il ya des dames
avec des bottes avec des petits chocs au
gré des cravaches et ils paient très
cher pour se faire taper ça aurait pu
d'ailleurs changé ou ce qu'est ce que
vous appelez des coûts madame le
ministre a pu rester un peu rapide
anglais fait ça très rapide alors là
maintenant notre page de publicité wind
n'hésitons pas à mettre une page de
publicité au beau milieu d'une émission
pourquoi pas nous avons besoin sur
antenne 2 alors vous allez voir cette
ces publicités sont très célèbres mais
elles sont un petit peu spécial elles
ont été faites par réalisé par agnès de
la rive et vous allez voir que les
hommes ont pris la place des femmes et
les femmes la place des hommes jeunes ou
la paix revienne à sa place
j'ai tout rangé ses fans
webb rompu dans la moi je les rincer
avec naylor vous croyez qu'elle va
remarquer
je me sens bien au
elle a remarqué moi je trouve qu'avec
abel bon là j'ai plus propre enfin comme
qui dirait est plus blanc vous fait
confiance en tout le linge délicat pour
mes caleçons mais mes maillots et et
puis pour une grosse un âge aussi enfin
celui où il ya beaucoup de tâches dessus
parce qu'il faut vous dire que ma femme
est à la maison des bleus de travail et
qui sont carrément noir alors je fais
confiance à la bulle
mais si vous voulez je vais vous faire
une proposition je vous des changes
battre baril d'abel contre 2 varésines
autonome et giorgio mais ça m'intéresse
pas moi j'aime mieux à belmont mais si
vous vivez vous l'approuvez la propreté
d'abel fans ne s'échangent pas nous
règlerons ton cette affaire ensemble dès
que vous le désirez je vous pour le
croire lui permettre à l'assurance de ma
vive les ratios oui oui oui
oui alors voilà madame le ministre et
son passé de cette publicité un peu
inversés c'est une excellente idée mais
vous avez vu là pour vous aider mais tu
sais toujours les femmes qui
publiquement et peut-être un certain
nombre de téléspectateurs se rendre en
compte de ce que c'est que la vie des
femmes vues à la télévision
de quoi vous dégoûter de la vie
conjugale c'est est ce que c'est une vie
conjugale à la télévision on fait de la
nuit toute la journée
et quand on était pas mal ici on essaie
d'amadouer un mari irascible à coups de
sucreries ou de fromage
alors même si c'est vrai moi je crois
qu'il ne faut pas le répéter deux fois
par jour parce que ça pourrait être la
cause de la baisse de l'activité
josé artur commentaire moi je trouve ça
ridicule mais je soupçonne le ridicule
quand c'est la vrai aussi que je suis
franchement ce genre de stupidités et
cette escroquerie qui est la publicité
faible à un jeu vers je vais j'ai fait
alors là je ne suis pas misogyne brefs
délais puisque le 10 octobre une
publiphobe monsieur le grammairien ça
mais ce que je veux dire c'est que ça il
faut pas rigoler parce que c'est une
anticipation c'est pas une plaisanterie
prospective qu'on trouve ça très laid
fait mais moi ton mais moi je trouve
très bien imager troquerait bien d'aller
à la maison d'avoir une femme qui va
boulonnais qui me rapporte le pognon
schéma petite lessive ya des machins
ça me dérange pas mais ce que ça me
rappelle c'est un peu m que j'ai eues
j'étais bien j'étais un bébé bio tech à
mon père et deux qui étaient je peux pas
vous le dire ça mais rachetés parce que
c'était assez plein c'est peut-être le
quelqu'un parmi les hydropathes conseil
perdu 184 1 peut-être mis le couteau est
ce que ça va est-ce que c'est non pas du
tout est ce que senna j'ai su ça est en
tout cas mon père on peut bien les deux
premiers volets préposition reprendront
cette discussion tout terrain et moi je
vais passer ce petit poème dont je me
sens bien peut-être je ne peux pas
regarder vous faire rater je portais des
hydropathes hésitera pas que ce sens les
gens étymologiquement les gens qui
souffraient de l'eau c'est à dire c'est
une façon peut-être de maurice doit être
autour du chat ne le dira pas la voici
s'agit d'une femme
la voici prises par les vielles bonne
petite ménagère mais dont l'envers du
tablier laisse à nu dans saison dernière
il est vrai qu'il faisait très chaud et
je sois de cette amende record comme je
m'approchais belle les doigts tanguy
verte en a pas elle ne se retourne à pas
pour dire je prends de vincennes et à la
fin il a dit j'ai pas bien fait lundi
j'ai trop de vaisselle bon j'ai pas
compris c'est bon
l'abstention des gros bovins et les
porcs j'en ai je vais vous considérez
que ça peut plus jamais arriver ça peut
je crois que ça peut arriver toujours ça
mais en fait sûrement a tout de même
admis que ton attention attention
maintenant il ya des machines les
moissons la chine elle ne dit pas j'ai
trouvé celle émanant en prépa sont
vachement à coucher c'est plutôt à
produire mais c'est ce que jouer madame
la ministre
restons dans chez la femme objet voici
interviewé par gilles lambert un
photographe de femmes nues et une très
très très ravissante jeune femme qui a
l'habitude de poser nue voulait rabaissé
au niveau d'un objet de consommation
érotique nous le voulons vraiment fou
août et regarder toutes les femmes dans
la rue elles pensent qu'à se montrer
le soir elles sortent soit à moitié à
poil sur les plages elles sont toutes
nues elles ont toutes des robes
transparentes je vois pas en quoi ça
problème érotique dans ce que vous
demandez je fais des photos de femmes
nues parce qu'elles sont belles et
qu'elles ont envie de se montrer
c'est tout est ce que toutes les filles
acceptent de poser pour vous dansez dans
cet état je dirais pas toutes les filles
mais je n'ai jamais eu de grands
problèmes pour trouver des filles qui
veulent poser nues y en a beaucoup qui
me téléphonent même pour eux pour poser
nue il y en a des quantités qui écrivent
au magazine où il ya des femmes nues
pour poser nue j'ai même une fois des
parents qui m'ont téléphoné pour me
demander de me reposer leur fille nue
alors je vois pas où est le problème
finalement je vous avez une fille vous
mène donc j'ai pas tué si vous aviez une
fille disant de 15 ans 16 ans est-ce que
vous accepteriez qu'elle pose nue tu
vois qu'il a photographié le 1er mai qui
comme posé nue pour ses magazines
est-ce que ça c'est un problème pour
vous est-ce que vous avez des
difficultés au début j'en ai quelques
unes mais maintenant absolument aucune
parce que ça se passe toujours un
conditions très simple très nature n ya
jamais de de voyeur vraiment qu'ils sont
là ça se passe toujours avec des gens
généralement que j'aime bien et c'est
assez privé il ya tout le monde
le fait très naturellement est ce que
quand vous avez décidé de poser nue dans
ses magazines est autour de vous des
amis ont manifesté une certaine
réprobation
alors oui et c'était surtout les femmes
des amis disant mais oui oui mais bien
sûr mais elle a posé nue mais par
exemple votre chance et ce qu'il a mais
ce genre de photo ila n'était pas au
début il a ni parce qu'il a vu ce genre
de photos que je sais c'est toujours
très très beau et très joli et il avoue
lui même que il aimerait bien sorti avec
une telle fille il est presque étonné
par des fois du résultat que ça donne
mais il n'est pas choqué quand même on
s'assoit pas nous avait dit que tout le
monde ne vous était pas d'accord quand
vous avez fait ces décisions là par
hasard nous avons votre maman ici ce
qu'on peut lui demander comment ce devis
réagi en voyant comment vrai j -c
oriente nu sur les magazines mais tout
d'abord je ne suis pas d'accord
bien sûr mais je laisse ma fille quand
même entièrement dit peut-être un peu
quand même
[Musique]
oui finalement les censeurs semble-t-il
ce sont les femmes plutôt les femmes des
amis vous avez remarqué samedi amy oui
enfin là je pense que ça brille un tout
autre sentiment non qu'elles sont
immondes on se dit peut-être quand on
voit cette ravissante fille les billets
qu'elle nous parle monsieur qui a vu la
photo nue l'imaginent nous avait un peu
travailler son imagination
je sais me paraît assez normale puisse
être saisie doit être une mère du cd
pour l'érotisme je suis je suis pas
d'accord et puis je dois vous reconnu
avec monsieur kaplan qui dirait des
poèmes fédérer zus 2 2 vous avez écrit
qui me paraît beaucoup mieux exprimer
l'érotisme qui sonde vers de paul valéry
qui dit ni lui ni connu le temps d'un
singe nu entre deux chemises bien le
temps d'un sein d'une autre de chemise
je trouve ça beaucoup plus érotique que
les ravissantes photos de cette personne
reste un point de vue tout à fait
personnel pourtant il ya une chose au
point de vue de l'environnement
apportent une contribution quand même un
rennais de la femme n'est ce pas parce
qu'il s'est pas passé grand chose il est
temps parce que c'est toujours c'est
encore un jeune gay parce qu'au fond il
ya de jolies femmes et d'autres qui le
sont moins mais pas pour les jolies
femmes c'est toujours la même jour la
nuit l'air la minute de la femme pour
les autres ce n'est plus ce que je dis
je dis je dis je vous rendez compte de
ce qu annonce mais c'est absolument dans
la brèche
c'est une évidence elle explose je veux
dire exactement qu'une femme qui les
passionne je lis et des riverains n'est
plus avec nous sommes absolument plus
c'est plus un homme qui est vieux qui
n'est pas désirable qui est fatigué qui
est chômeur nous ce sens qu'il vient
mais qui est canon métier cadran chômage
etc
il est aussi dans une situation sociale
ne s'agit pas d'être un sauvage vous
avez dit non je dis que c'est toujours
leur de la femme quand elle est jeune
mais bien sûr mais je te juger du jour
c'est une évidence reste monsieur les
deux jeux mais que vous avez dit
justifierait h salle et tout ce qui se
passe dans le monde n'est pas non mais
je veux plus être obligés d'être vrai
mais j'aimerais qu'on dise que c'est une
constatation évidente comment je ne suis
pas jaloux des genoux
mais j'ai bien vu que ça veut dire
alors ma deuxième contre les puces arm a
promis la contribution c'est fait pour
faire plaisir mais ce palier une année
ou en face à corps masculin et au
féminin ayant une chose absolument
considérable que mes recherches de
graminées rien je consulte beaucoup les
dictionnaires il m'arrive de lire
quelques fois l'ailé de regarder des
images voisine du beau jeu cherche un
milieu sans tomber dans un grand
dictionnaire encyclopédique illustrait
parfois en couleur que je ne citerai pas
qui a dit volume n'est ce pas de tomber
sur une page que je sais quels mots y
avait une planche représentant le bassin
de la femme le bassin de l'homme n'est
ce pas en couleur avec des petites
flèches comme ça qu'ils renvoyaient à
des mots tout autour qui rayonnait et
qui désigne les organes flux pas
pourquoi je me suis amusé à warcq
c'était et abattu est ce que vous ne
saviez pas que vous allez voir non mais
ça ce sont des bonnes heures ce sont des
bonheurs de grammes mais rien c'est
comme ça que les choses se font très bon
alors je me suis aperçu que sur la
planche représentant le bassin de
l'homme les petites flèches en renvoyer
n'est ce pas des détails anatomiques
absolument précis pour les organes
génitaux et stupeur c'est pas croyable
dans un dictionnaire encyclopédique
khaldi volume qui est un des plus de
l'époque actuelle pour le bassin de la
femme n'est ce pas un organe que même
principal on peut dire essentiel que je
ne citerai pas ma favorite dont
l'étymologie dans l'étymologie
pourquoi parce que j'ai à parier je me
suis trouvé comment voulez vous que je
ne sois pas intimité en voyant fils
maison aussi sérieuses que celles dont
ge pas ou n'est ce pas aussi important
que s'est abstenu alors je dirais donc
je reproche je vais jusqu'au bout je
reproche à la maison la route dans son
grand dictionnaire encyclopédique mais
ce que je ne pas avoir mis deux petites
flèches n'est ce pas pu indiquer que le
sable avait des lèvres et un clitoris
car ça ne figure pas et à côté pour
l'homme il ya la verge
je trouve je trouve que ce que je trouve
que cette excision cette exception
typographique était absolument
monstrueux c'est votre ville se trouve
partout pas seulement la sienne que
laisser cette pièce de coke linky est
très misogyne la paix chez soi mais on y
voit une pauvre épouse quémander mendier
l'argent du ménage à son mari que les
feuilletonistes alors juste dans cette
scène de ou demande l'argent vous allez
l'avoir jouée par francis perrin et à
nice ni gallia dans une mise en scène de
jeunes et hubert mais là aussi nous
avons interverti les rôles à la belle
question n'ont jamais plus nous sommes
le 1er octobre j'en ai plus j'en ai plus
rien savoir si j'en avais je l'aurais
pris je suppose que je me lève la nuit
pour te voler au dessus de forme de
voler mon du fait qu'elle nouvelles
furent elles viennent chercher la pause
rien du tout 7e dan le 1er de chaque
mois l'argent nécessaire aux ménages
pendant que moi pour l'argent filet et
la bourse et à ce texte dans le mois et
à bout c'est aussi ça me fait faire
puisque les 28 donne moi ce qui me
revient
les gars étaient belles phrases pour tes
romans n'ont plus besoin que moi donc tu
dis est proche plus proche même que je
suis le pain je veux absolument très
curieux tu devrait s'établir en voyant
ces techniques dont le rsa mais viennois
en attendant nous allons réguler icô ne
visera 800 français
j'étais là par quatre stages j'ai donné
leur temps menés 12
ça sera plus commode et 56 50 ou à la
daf et puis c'est que l'argent qu'est
l'argent à l'argent pour le mois y'a pas
le compte
comment pas le coup non mais qui alors
enfin tu deviens un imbécile ou de 800
francs au 2t vit dans un corps presque
intégrale fois ça va donner moi mais non
pourquoi parce que tu nettoies - oui toi
tu apprends moi qu'est-ce que tu ne
chantes tu vois votre d argent je vois
vu d'autres cartes et des avances et
d'économie et de l'ordre mois dans l'est
dans la barre se voit depuis cinq ans
nous sommes mariés qui s'écartent de la
question il ne s'agit pas de terreur
vertu mais bien de ses imperfections
lesquels hélas son nombre de voix
étaient 150 fondement l'étude monge par
là une folle
quel est son fondement les 150
fondamente que j'ai eu le regret de ta
figé en punition de ses écarts de
langage de la pertinence y faire sur
bellion en tout genre etc etc
tu ne comprends pas poursuit l'homme
je vais lire le détail couvrir la vérité
du 1er septembre pour avoir tranché une
question sans connaître le premier mot
puis convaincu de son erreur qui est
propre au nez de parti pris avec une
insigne mauvaise foi afin d'avoir rennes
ont quand même pour m'exaspérer que moi
valentine femmes bodéré patienter 12395
comme zizou qe2 pour avoir valentine
ayant exprimé le désir de dynea quart
d'heure plus tôt fait servir un quart
d'heure plus tard et répondu à ladite
ballantyne avec qui se cognait sans
acrimonie
si tu n'es pas content tu vas t'en dîner
ailleurs qu'il faut s'attendre en soi et
du terc pour le birdie
te rappelles-tu la fois où j'étais
pardonner d'être rentré à 7 heures du
matin 71 francs combien 71e pour rien
quand on a pardonné aux gens ne doit pas
être tout le temps le leur cornet aux
oreilles et fred pas donner quoi
expliquer cette fois que j'avais manqué
le dernier
et oh mon dieu je comprends pas c'est
crois que péremptoire et tant qu'à faire
que d'être ta victime j'aime autant ne
pas en avoir d'obligation je compte du
tech ça va durer longtemps
quoi tant que tu ne seras pas revenu un
plus juste sentiment des égards auquel
je crois et que j'exige désormais
plusieurs ajustements mourir de rire
bien entendu voilà cinq ans que
j'imaginais excuses et son injustice et
que je me crée des devoirs tout exprès
pour avoir le souci de les remplir
aujourd'hui je pousse la prétention
jusqu'à supposer que peut-être un jour
une fois par hasard tu as pu en
apercevoir et en avoir été touché c'est
bien moi qui suis dans mon temps
bon quand tu auras ceux causés nous le
dira
pyatt est coté à sept jours mais 150
temps passes tu veux pas me donner ce
que tu trouves la maison une lourde
j'étais nous avons des charges je ne dis
pas je te prie avec 650 francs il me
sera impossible d'y faire face
s'ils attendent recteurs inspecteurs à
ton aise dans son kit pour vivre de
toledo avec la vie leur grand père tu
t'arranges rat comme tu pourras mais si
je ne trouve pas mes repas la nourriture
saine et copieux ce que réclame mon bon
appétit j'irai guinée dehors à tes frais
bien entendu c'est ton dernier mot alors
où tu me donne mon argent où je me jette
par la fenêtre par la presse elle est
top
sarko contente
kiel 1re d'offres pour avoir menacé
ballottine de se suicider sous ses yeux
tentant ainsi d'exploiter la tendresse
de cette expérience femmes 4 fort 95 on
ne l'avoir pas fait dix ans qu'il le
sait ce que tu cherches
je sais vous devant dire tu s'oubliera
pas vraiment très 64 centimes pour
s'être servies au cours de la
conversation de locutions emprunté à un
roman de kipé car il ya trop longtemps
je souffre au sens plein journée a fait
genre cauchemar
[Applaudissements]
après ces images de francis perrin non
ferreux en train de cuisiner il est
l'heure de présenter mélanine de la
ministre un fieffé miso d'un gastronome
il s'agit du chroniqueur gastronomique
christian guy à qui j'ai demandé s'il
selon lui les fâcheux mais leur
cuisinière que les sommes non les femmes
ne font pas la cuisine elles font de la
cuisine belfond elles ne font pas la
cuisine la meilleure preuve c'est qu'il
n'y a jamais eu de grands chefs qui
était femme qu'est ce qu'ils sont des
femmes
il n'y a jamais eu un grand auteur
gourmand qui était une femme
et ça ça s'explique de différentes
manières d'une part parce que faire
naître un grand chef c'est beaucoup de
travail c'est très dur c'est très
difficile et je suis bien que maintenant
est allée des cuisines sont climatisés à
gaz électricité c'est quand même
beaucoup moins dur votre foi mais c'est
quand même un boulot extrêmement dur ça
c'est une chose
et puis a également une autre chose
c'est que ce que je reproche à la
cuisine criminels vont aux femmes qui
font qu'ils font la cuisine normalement
elles le font tous les jours même c'est
pas de cette cuisine l'est dont nous
allons parler de ça c'est plus une tous
les jours ça c'est très fatigant aussi
je veux bien voir mais elle s'y applique
de moins en moins elle freine du congelé
maintenant c'est invraisemblable pour
parler ouais ça alors ça vraiment c'est
l'oeuf tresses et la déchéance tué le
cheikh mais il ya plus de bosses dames
il y avait la mère brazier un labeur
brésil avait des chefs alors alors nous
estimons qu'aujourd'hui les les mères
lyonnaises les mers du sud la mer blanc
c'est bien s'étale sur wii c'est du
folklore c'est du tout le cas je me suis
tout de suite tout ça c'était il ya
cinquante ans il ya cent ans lorsque les
femmes c'est vive est une autre époque
et savait encore le temps de faire une
musique maintenant nous vivons une
époque nouvelle est maintenant il ya
plus de merde de merde
géant generes que les femmes ont du
talent cuisine certainement pas
certainement pas voyons enfin s'asseoir
et on les verrait avoir inventé un aplat
où l'on verrait un baucus femmes on
verrait quelque chose comme ça voilà la
meilleure preuve juste ou pas et émile
un chef n'a pas de lumière vous allez
dire une chefs et cheftaines je peux
déjà voilà la lâche et de l'étoile d'or
or even milan vainqueur alors peut-être
qu'elles ont tellement fait la cuisine
dans leur vie les femmes que leur
ambition de se situe pas là elle
pourrait quand même continuer à le faire
ce serait quand même très agréable
non mais attendez ce que vous connaissez
c'est l'esprit créateur de l'assureur
français c'est l'esprit créateur la
femme a peut-être trop d'imagination
lorsqu'il fait un plat ce que peut faire
un grand plat elle ne suit pas la
recette classique alors on ne sait pas
du tout ce que ça va donner
et ça c'est terrible d'en cuisine d'une
femme dont il ne réussit jamais deux
fois le même plat ça c'est pas possible
voilà la seule à ce qu'elle veut faire
un plein bon lll mais ces petits oignons
et me jeter et puis d'un coup le cpl et
se dit le nom de nous est ce que je vais
avoir des bras pour sortir ce soir elle
file condensats dans sa salle à manger
ou de céline elle est belle elle est ou
réussir le morceau de viande il est
complètement cramé le congrès tous à
elles n'ont pas d'idée de suite donne
pour la grèce lors de leur choix même la
ministre va répondre non mais vous
faisant les femmes n'ont pas d'idée de
suite laisse brûler la viande tout le
monde c'est tous les jours pour rentrer
chez vous vous dis n'est jamais bien est
ce qu'elle se mette d'accord il conteste
l'esprit créatif de la femme en cuisine
pas nous parlons pas de la cuisine tous
les jours mais il considère que les
grands lacs où est retranché m
ça n'a pas beaucoup de rapport avec le
fait de laisser brûler les oignons de
lucie femme et l'amener à l'esprit
créateur et l'esprit de faire une bonne
recette
mesbah et ses deux sites impossible la
meilleure preuve nous disait citez moi
un très bon argument tout à l'heure et
que les conditions dans lesquelles on a
on fait la cuisine quand on est un grand
chef d'un grand restaurant sont presque
intolérable physiquement pour une femme
c'est tout à fait le même principe
ainsi parle pas pendant des années avec
les minières à charbon et que les femmes
n'ont pas fait ce métier là j'ai pas sûr
qu'aujourd'hui avec les conditions
nouvelles l'électricité à muret iii
hongrie qui placerait son ambition dans
le fait de faire une grande cuisine n'y
arriverai pas mais je serais très étonné
qu'il y ait une femme qui place son
ambition dans le fait de réussir une
grande cuisine voilà ce crois que c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui est bloqué
pour le moment si vous le permettez je
crois ce qu'elles n'ont pas envie de
faire de faire baisser bien mélanger dit
ne se sentent pas certains non à
l'éventuelle bon restons-en là madame la
ministre ce qui empêche faut bien le
dire les femmes de gagner leur vie
gagnée mais souvent ce sont les enfants
à une discrimination l'embauchent ce
temps j'avais des enfants peuvent
apprendre des choses alors voici alors
on va vous fournir une preuve de cette
discrimination par les enfants mais là
aussi nous avons interverti les rôles
vous allez voir mal karimov ce qu'a joué
le rôle d'une chef du personnel d'une
grande entreprise et c'est une
réalisation de josé avec un dayan
[Musique]
choisi pour la place de magasinier votre
âge 22 ans
célibataire oui
bien c'est non non non non à la bonne
heure je viens de refuser la place à un
garçon qui a des rues de gosse en deux
ans c'est un début comprenez que nous
pouvons pas former les collaborateurs
pour leur payer des grangettes paternité
ben c'est à dire mais vous vous
envisagez de vous marier quand ben c'est
à dire que c'est tellement jeunes de
l'est toute la vie devant vous pas des
enfants non feinte madame je voulais
vous dire que oui ben petit point des
enfants jean noël
vous avez des enfants oui madame 3
je suis un père célibataire
je les ai eus alors il fallait bien que
les élèves
vous avez déjà que magazine non mais non
non alors c'est inutile parce que pour
briguer la place et magali écoute avoir
une expérience d'au moins 6 mois
ces deux
[Musique]
une scène tu sèmes triste parce qu'elle
éveille est vrai non sens inverse en
sens inverse mais un jour elle peut se
produire dans ce sens là je veux dire ce
qui est triste la gorge vécu une seconde
c'est d'être sérieuse c'est c'est
l'intolérance général aux enfants qui
est horrible on peut dire il ya cas
précis c'est amusant moi j'adore dire
des choses comme ça je vais pas dire le
nom de la banque quand même mal à se
reconnaître
c'est une grande banque nationalisée et
celle agences de bastia donc j'ai
principaux peut pas et il ya six mois le
fondé de pouvoir à lourdes et toutes les
femmes à ce qu'il ya il en avait marre
des congés de maladie paternité
scolarité vachin et il a gardé une seule
femme
les habitants de bastia qui connaissent
cette banque qui vont se passer et vient
et ça fait c'est vrai ça c'est
intéressant s'amusent à tester
alors moi je vais vous raconter autre
chose c'est une réunion d'experts
patronaux organisée sous l'égide de
l'osce aider et il ya un expert on n'est
pas trop qui est dégoûté moi je veux
dire la vérité pourquoi fait-on travail
et les femmes parce qu'on est payé moins
cher parce que on peut les mettre dehors
en ayant moins d'ennuis on supporte
mieux les licenciements et parce qu'elle
coût égal elles reviennent moins cher et
les machines alors on continuera à les
faire travailler les femmes vous
inquiéter oui mais je crois je crois
aussi qu'il faudrait trouver un salaire
de la femme au foyer
je vous proposerai temps madame la
ministre
déjà s'il vous plaît monsieur misogyne
je vous propose d'écouter un autre fief
et miso de la politique celui-là il
s'agit d'alexandre sanguinetti il est
interviewé par anne sinclair à et c'est
un film de dominique pages voici donc
avec cendres sanguinetti
vous m'avez dit les femmes c'est un
sujet détestable c'est vrai mais non je
suis pas un sujet détestable dans les
sociétés européennes 40 ans qu'il est
réglée alors qu'elle vrais problèmes de
la femme se pose dans les sociétés non
européennes alors en france qu'elle se
plaignent par femme il faut toujours se
plaint les hommes se plaignent bien
pourquoi est ce que les femmes ne se
plaindrait pas le problème est de savoir
ce que l'on attende la vie l'égalité de
la femme est évidente normal nécessaire
à une condition c'est qu'elle n'oublie
pas la différence et la complémentarité
si elle se présente uniquement en rival
de loeb sur les même plan que l'homme
il y a beaucoup de choses pour qu'ils ne
soient pas de la même force thor quel
plan était légale surtout le plan
juridique nous parlons de la look un
chercheur et un cac est en capacité en
capacité elles sont aussi intelligentes
que les hommes
quelquefois plus est elles sont
parfaitement capables d'affronter les
métiers d'hommes nous le savons tous est
cette année de la femme vous a hérité
agacer ou fait prendre conscience d'un
certain nombre de choses non coûteux
vraiment jupons n'ayant matin j'ai pas
pris conscience parce qu'à une année de
la femme qui avait un problème de la
femme
lorsque le général leur a donné le droit
de vote en 1945 alors que les hommes
avaient le droit de vote depuis 1848
je reconnais qu'on aurait pu se dessiner
avant mais à côté d'un confort juridique
elles réclament aussi un confort moral
ne semble pas le leur offrir on le
trouve qu'en soi même il n'y a pas donné
de la femme qui donnera le confort moral
qui que ce soit mais les hommes peuvent
prendre une certaine considération des
femmes qu'ils avaient pas toujours vous
savez quand on lit la littérature autres
vers logiciel qu'on constate que les
hommes sont plus souvent victimes que
pau
ah oui oh oui vous avez des exemples
plein dispose lac c'est la littérature
littérature d'enliser l'observation de
son temps dans l'histoire les hommes ont
été plus fréquemment victimes des femmes
ah oui y apprenons d'un doute car les
femmes ont parlé procédé qui leur
appartiennent dominés les hommes
beaucoup plus souvent que les hommes ont
dominé les femmes
vous avez l'impression que durant cette
année de la femme il ya une
revendication plus grande du sexe
féminin ou ayant une agressivité de la
part des femmes qui ne sont pas fans
ça c'est vrai parce que les autres n'ont
pas de problème à se poser les hommes
sont à leur pied qu'est ce que vous
appelez des femmes pas femmes je me
demande d'époque detroit ni de nom fait
type de femme c'est plutôt george sand
ou plutôt martine carol et si on prend
les milieux à dreux mieux non non non
non pas du tout se rapproche plutôt de
laquelle des deux d'aucune du nil
intellectuelle mais journal ni les
jolies choses
vous savez en vérité il faudrait
plusieurs femmes pour arriver à réaliser
un leader le féminin c'est curieux comme
tous les hommes refusent de choisir
finale mais pas s'il ya pas moyen sur le
choix
oui ou qu'ils n'osent pas nous parce
qu'il est impossible de faire le choix
vous avez pas peur des femmes du tout
votre commentaire est choquée de voir y
ait des choses très drôle d'un cd qui
n'était il ya des choses très justes
aussi quand il dit qu'il ya autant de
femmes que d'hommes peu raté leur vie
c'est vrai mais quelque chose me frappe
il dit n'est ce pas les femmes donc à
être des femmes elles ont les hommes à
leurs pieds alors nous en revenons à ce
qu'on disait tout à l'heure je voudrais
savoir jusqu'à quel âge on a un homme à
ses pieds et alors après qu'est ce qu'on
fait avec ninon de lenclos oui au fait
on a eu quand même un petit peu partout
au niveau des biens et et si on n'a pas
un physique thème enfin qu'on est des
hommes à ses pieds alors on disparaît
complètement
ce soit dans la vision des hommes y
compris celle d'alexandrie qualité qui
encore époque d'autre part du les choses
porte intelligente et pas juste vous
n'existez cas quand des challenges avec
ton nom c'est vrai aux lilas de l'esprit
des choses justes quand je peux aussi
être très désagréable mais pas sur ce
terrain là et donc je ne vois pas
comment on peut concevoir les femmes
uniquement dans cette situation là vous
êtes une femme et vous avez un homme à
vos pieds je voudrais savoir parmi les
femmes qui ne regarde combien de femmes
ont des hommes alors qu'ils vont bien
madame la ministre ça y est l'émission
touche à sa fin encore un jour c'est
vrai est l'année de la femme ouf c'est
fini donc les normales je vous donne
animaux tenez de la faim dans nos
émissions vous l'aurez toujours
correctement et cet amour
attendez vous avez un grammairien si
vous cherchez à mon nom comme le combat
continue camarades
[Musique]